mondialisation du terrorisme évidemment
c'est un mot sur lequel il va falloir
revenir à ce qu'on a à faire
effectivement à une international du
terrorisme à une fabrique de camicas
sans précédent sommes nous nous français
visés par des ch
qui sont ces volontaires y compris
français on l'a compris aussi qu'ils
rejoignent l'organisation est faut-il
intervenir lourdement militairement sur
place avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
voilà 14 ans après le 11-septembre et
quatre ans après la mort de ben laden
les questions qui se posent donc à
nouveau et sur lesquelles on va débattre
avec nous ce soir le sénateur des
hauts-de-seine jacques gauthier
vice-président l'est républicain de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées
pierre conesa ancien du ministère de la
défense maître de conférences à sciences
po paris auteur de la fabrication de
l'ennemi ou comment tuer avec sa
conscience pour soi c'est publié chez
robert laffont
pierre jean luizard l'historien
spécialiste du moyen-orient chercheur au
cnrs auteur du piège dahesh l'état
islamique ou le retour de l'histoire aux
éditions de la découverte et christophe
ayad rédacteur en chef internationale au
monde je précise que le réalisateur
jérôme fritel qui est en tournage à
l'étranger n'a pas pu être avec nous on
comprend pourquoi bien évidemment mais
on va discuter de son film et ce mot
donc qui conclut son film mondialisation
du terrorisme est ce qu'on doit dire
d'abord est peut-être très reconnaissant
que des ces nouvelles al qaïda c'est
réutiliser des rubriques existantes si
vous nous sommes toujours besoin d'un
référencement comme un phénomène nouveau
apparaît c'était la nouvelle forme
d'effectivement de brandir d'une
mouvance donc je qualifierais mois de
salafistes plutôt islamistes djihadistes
au sens effectivement où la violence est
légitimée par leur discours est donc ça
une caractéristique locale très très
forte maintenant est-ce que c'est
capable de se mondialiser ça je crois
que c'est un débat qui reste ouvert le
fameux al gbagbo dit qu'on voit dans le
documentaire c'est un nouveau ben laden
pas est-ce qu'il ya cette aura
international qu'avait ben laden cette
capacité à frapper sur d'autres
territoires que sur le sien c'est un
grand point d'interrogation le pouvoir
réel du khalife de l'état islamique est
évidemment difficile à cerner lui même
s'est autoproclamé qualif alors qu'il
n'a aucune des qualités au regard de la
tradition sunnites pour être khalifa il
ne jouit d'aucune légitimation des
autorités religieuses qui est
normalement le cas pour être reconnu
comme calife et il a il est assez
ignorant en sciences religieuses
puisqu'il ne fait que quatre ans
d'études en théologie donc c'est un
phénomène tout à fait nouveau qui n'a
rien à voir avec le califat ottoman ni
même en sans doute avec les qualifs bien
diriger mais par d'aubaine n était plus
qu à pécs à ben laden n'avait pas de
projet étatique 1 c'est la grande
différence est la vraie différence entre
les deux organisations il ya plusieurs
différences mais
il y a la volonté proclamée de
construire un état et cette volonté est
mise en application et le califat renée
une des expressions c'est très important
et si je veux vais sur ce terrain au
début du débat c'est pour bien
comprendre quel est le danger réel que
représente pour nous en france des ch ou
français dice des châles ambitions
locales ou une ambition mondiale
c'est une ambition d'abord locale c'est
à dire que donc on peut très bien ne pas
s'en mêler vous et pourquoi je vous pose
la question parce que six années qu
locale après tout on peut se dire
laissons les faire oui mais c'est une
telle force de déstabilisation une telle
force d'attraction que ça a fini par
toucher des terrains autres que ceux où
il est né dèche au départ répond aux
besoins et aux frustrations des
populations sunnites d'irak et de syrie
après son projet la mise en scène denis
branger et fui de l'autre la main
aujourd'hui en irak les sunnites ont été
marginalisés écrasé en irak après
l'invasion de 2003 et en syrie depuis le
règne de la famille assad
et encore plus depuis 2011 le
soulèvement la révolution que vous
l'appelez comme vous voulez qui a donné
lieu à une répression sans précédent du
régime contre une communauté cette
communauté sunnite donc d'être répond à
cela c'est le fruit de cela de deux de
ces deux pays qui en plus sombre
relativement récent et où on a beaucoup
de liens de part et d'autre de la
frontière où on remet en cause des
frontières relativement neuve est jeune
voilà maintenant est-ce que des chats un
projet mondial en proclamant le califat
oui d'une certaine manière et en
utilisant de façon massive les réseaux
sociaux pour faire appel pour attirer
des jeunes ou des personnes du moins
vivant dans des pays considérés comme
non musulmans oui à l'évidence et qu'il
ya une volonté aussi de tisser un réseau
d'alliances avec d'autres groupes
ailleurs que sur le continent fait que
sur lot dans la région du moyen-orient
notamment en afrique et en asie que ce
soit avec boko haram au nigeria ou libye
avec eux donc il ya une internationale
du terroriste dont dahesh est un maillon
mais pas forcément le driver noyau mais
c'est le doigt y aura besoin de penser
simplement mais il faut qu'ils
s'habituent à l'avancé simplement les
choses se veut un pays et se veut un
projet deux choses qui s'articule et qui
de temps en temps sont divergentes et de
te l'entendre convergentes jacques
gauthier est un danger pour la france
soit aller plus loin ou pas c'est un
danger pour la france comme en quoi pour
l'ensemble des nations occidentales
ce qu'il faut dire et je rejoins tout à
fait ce qui vient d'être précisée sexy
le berceau est en irak et en syrie
on voit bien qu'ils peuvent grâce à leur
communication à leur marketing
ils peuvent devenir une force
d'entraînement pour déjà dispo temps
ciel des terroristes potentiels à
travers le sahel à travers d'autres
régions tous les pays où il ya une
dictature ou un régime trop dur ou à
l'opposé un régime fragilisé
déstabiliser failli on voit le cadet des
voix pour un terroriste pour une
contestation armée et 7e fabriquer ce
que vous craignez que des ch ne se
vantera l'organiser une fabrique du
terrorisme pourquoi fabrique gagne mais
il a symbolise et appartements où il a
su communiquer à travers les réseaux
sociaux comme personne ne l'avait fait
avant lui on verra tout à l'heure
beaucoup de ceux qui veulent porter une
action terroriste
ce rallye symboliquement à neige qui
tentent pas de recevoir d'ordres de
dallage qui dope à mon avis en donne pas
mais simplement pour avoir une
légitimité
essayez d'être une force d'attraction
parce que grâce à cette communication
sur les réseaux sociaux on sent bien
qu'un grand mouvement verdaich des
forêts une fighter les combattants venus
d'occident
mais même en australie ou aux français
un seul envoi de même en australie dans
un pays qui se veut
ouvert aux différences culturelles et
cultuelles il ya des régions qui se
mobilisent pour venir se battre pour des
jonques c'est un grand mouvement mondial
qui dépasse simplement les nations
européennes
d'accord il s'appelait comme ça c'est à
dire qu'il ya un temps médiatique un
temps historique le temps historique
c'est effectivement la poussée du ca la
fille qui grosso modo trop son origine
en arabie saoudite dans les années 60
très c'est sûr que 79 quant à la
révolution islamique d'iran
la grande terreur de rials c'est
effectivement de penser que des chiffres
puissent prendre la cause la tête de la
cause du monde musulman et tout l'effort
religieux de l'arabie saoudite la
politique religieuse de l'arabie
saoudite 1 3 milliard de dollars par an
c'est à dire trois fois puisque faisait
l'union soviétique ans à sa belle époque
ça a été l'essentiel de la propagation
du salafisme avec création de deux
mosquées de madrassas de bibliothèques
de boer finir écoles religieuses les
mercedes qui a créé le mali s'est pas
d'âge
qu'elle crée boko haram se sait cette
diffusion là qui a constitué le bac g
autour duquel le projet d'asf toutacoo
trouve une cristallisation
mais c'est une évolution qui il
aujourd'hui l'arabie saudite combattait
sur le terrain beaucoup moins que ce
qu'elle ne combal et les houthis
nouveaux avions saoudiens non oui deux
fois moins que la france et à peu près
autant que la hollande et le danemark
réuni ouï dire que c'est un effort
relativement mesurée pour vous alors
besoin je crois qu'il ya une sensibilité
de la société saoudienne le seul modèle
ou et des c'est le modèle saoudien
couper les têtes dé couper les têtes
coupées les mains des voleurs au prix et
les femmes et interdire les autres
religions vous avez qu'à franchir la
frontière vous la trouvez moi je tire
l'attention sur un fait c'est que
l'arabie saoudite se construit un mur de
900 km de long sur plus long que le mur
israélien qui a pour seul but d'empêcher
des réfugiés iraquiens aussi rien
d'entrer dans le territoire c'est-à-dire
le seul pays qui a de l'argent et la td
de l'espace est le seul qui n'a commis
aucun réfugié
donc j'ai quand même des doutes sur la
solidité de la société on à dire la
volonté de la société saoudienne de se
battre contre contre belge
dernière question s'il faut un jour
mettre des troupes au sol est ce que
vous pensez que l'arabie saoudite va
aller voler au secours du régime chiite
de bagdad moi je le pense pas donc on
est dans une contradiction un c'est un
renouveau des relations de long terme
qu'on n'avait pas vu venir qu'on n'a pas
vu arriver
notre outil diplomatique n'avait
d'ailleurs pas assuré vocation à
surveiller cette évolution religieuse et
dont on a les contrecoups ici aussi
parce qu'on est ici aussi on a nos
salafistes alors la question qu'on va se
poser c'est est-ce qu'il faut nous qu'on
aille plus loin sur le terrain j'ai été
très frappée mois dans le documentaire
près vous également par cette phrase
d'hubert védrine ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères qui a l'air de
penser que finalement death ne peut pas
gagner
son objectif sur ce nouveau prix de
l'application d'une conception
totalement committee de la charia qui
visait entre durable et aux familles qui
ont la moitié
et puis yeux ça mais ces pays
l'éventuelle spa des pays ceux des
entités plutôt lent circuit ils ne
peuvent pas se brancher sur le monde
contraire puisqu'il le défi provoque une
indigne il s'isole deiss a déjà perdu
alors il ya eu ce débat il ya une
dimension je crois qu'il faut aborder
si l'on veut comprendre le caractère
international de ce qu'on appelle le
terrorisme de neige c'est le fait que
nous sommes confrontés aujourd'hui à
l'effondrement d'un certain nombre
d'états et que des shows prospère
précisément là où les états s'effondre
et l'une des prouesses de neige de
l'état islamique c'est à la fois un
ancrage très local qu en irak par
exemple c'est un ancrage dans une
minorité la minorité arabe sunnite avec
un discours internationaliste qui vise à
présenter d'ascom porteur d'un
universalisme face à l'universalisme des
lumières européens et occidentaux contre
modèle c'est un contre modèle et qui a
été d'une certaine façon qui se veut
l'héritier des printemps arabes dans la
mesure où les printemps arabes ont
illustré l'émergence de sociétés civiles
ça a dégénéré très vite sur un plan
confessionnel mais des cheveux le seul
protagoniste indépendant d'état
autoritaire dans la région ils
rencontrent du succès auprès des
populations lequel vraiment s'il ne
rencontrait pas de succès ne
comprendraient pas comment ces
militaires soul est toujours entre les
mains de l'état islamique
l'état islamique n'a pas reculé ou très
peu en irak il y a donc à une réflexion
à avoir sur les causes du succès de
l'état islamique et sur les raisons qui
font qu'un certain nombre de populations
préfère l'état islamique au gouvernement
irakien d'importance que vous dites
parce que ce qu'on entend c'est que
fait régner une forme de terreur qui
fait comme les taliban à l'époque on a
bien dit ce temps qui fait qu'on ne
s'oppose pas à la dèche vous dit non il
ya aussi de l'adhésion c'est le paradoxe
c'est le paradoxe des ch est capable de
promettre l'enfer à ses ennemis et aux
mécréants
c'est à dire et compris parmi les
musulmans ceux qui ne sont pas sunnites
les chiites les yézidis mais pour ceux
qui se conforment notamment en matière
de moeurs et qu'ils reconnaissent
l'autorité de l'état islamique
il y à la promesse d'une vie meilleure
un peu si vous voulez d'ailleurs cette
vie où les lire dans cette vaste zone au
parvis amanites et entre ceux qui ont le
droit de vivre et qui a acquis les
premiers un avenir meilleur et ceux qui
n'ont pas d'autre destin que de devoir
mourir de la neige c'est robin des bois
pour des certains sunnites irakiens 5000
syriens oui c'est à dire que là où c'est
pas tout à fait d'accord avec hubert
védrine c'est que si on va écouter ce
que disent les gens de mossoul et qu'ils
disent je suis moins racketter moins
torturé mois arrêtés dans la rue par des
shs que je ne l'étais par les soldats de
l'armée irakienne qui se comportait
comme une armée étrangère dans leur
propre pays parce que ces soldats aient
été recrutés sur une base uniquement
politique ou confisqué aux
professionnels et qu' ils lorsqu'ils
étaient postés à mossoul il avait
l'impression d'être en territoire
hostile donc une armée d'occupation
plutôt favorable a fini par remplacer
une armée d'occupation jugé
insupportable de l'occupation donc mais
ça reste de l'occupation oui mais
seulement je supporte les habitants de
mossoul
ils sont dus ceux qui ont accepté ce qui
ne sont pas partis le joug de dice mieux
aujourd'hui c'est pas le mot mais
comment dire qu'ils ont et le mal le
problème de bagdad en 2011 moi j'étais
le jour où
le soldat est le dernier soldat
américain se retirer je suis désolé les
y aller les habitants de bagdad la
capitale me parlait de six heures de
coupures voire 12 heures de coupure par
jour ce que vous dites sur l'irak ça
vaut pour la série pour des chantiers
c'est robin des bois aussi par certains
aspects pour certains et je peux vous
dire une chose c'est que quand tu
admires est tombé en france nous nous
sommes émus et pour les ruines de datant
de l'antiquité de cette très belle ville
pour laisser rien que signifie pas nuire
c'est une prison c'est un bagne dans le
dans lequel des générations d'opposants
pas seulement islamistes sont morts dont
des chats libérée tu admires fois
beaucoup des ch a détruit la
symboliquement la prison de palmyre la
baltique qui comble avec lui on a fait
tomber la belle série face à des
protagonistes dont on ne peut pas dire
que l'un est plus barbare que l'autre je
crois qu'il faut ajouter qu'à moscou
mais c'est vrai dans beaucoup de villes
les autorités administratives irakienne
du gouvernement de bagdad était
totalement corrompu et on voit que
mossoul et denrées essentielles avait un
prix énorme parce qu'elle est tout un
service de corruption et daher a rétabli
en luttant contre la corruption un prix
acceptable pour les données de base
donc si vous voulez l'homme de la rue
reconnaît pour lutte contre la
corruption on crucifix on décapite mais
en même temps il voit une amélioration
sa vie quotidienne
donc c'est pas les méchants et les bancs
l'homme de la rue à mossoul et dans les
autres villes qui sont tombés constate
une amélioration de leur cadre de vie
même si il ya ce retour en arrière il ya
ce retour au califat
on a basculé de milan à l'arrière mais
ils ont malgré tout le sentiment qu'ils
peuvent au moins manger et qui ne sont
pas inquiétés en permanence
donc il ya un danger à intervenir c'est
de se trouver face à des gens pour qui
des 7,1 jusqu'à employer le mot de
progrès mais apparemment en tout cas
dans leur vie quotidienne une
amélioration je voulais dire comme ça
hein pardonnez moi et puis un autre
élément c'est que cette violence à une
base religieuse c'est à dire qu'il
justifie toujours la violence la
violence qu'elle qu'en soit
l'application par le fait
qu'effectivement il s'agit d'appliquer
la charia au sens où s'étaient alors et
une même de la détente du prophète
évidemment discuter cette violence ça
vous regarde on viendra discuter de la
charia ou à critiquer la charia dont
qu'ils ont effectivement l argumentaire
très fort de légitimation de la violence
est encore une fois rappelez vous que
l'arrivée des talibans à kaboul s'était
aussi la remise en ordre du pays on
sortait de quelques années guerre civile
en algérie ont raconté par exemple une
histoire intéressante durant dix années
noires et on y avait un ivrogne qui
était un livre qui était qui avaient
voté pour le fils en 10e pour quoi tu
votes pour le fils qui boit de l'alcool
signé parce que si c'est un type du fln
qui me prend ma bouteille il va la
garder pour lui si cet indice la missive
à la casse et voilà vous avez la
contradiction que ce système là c'est à
dire qu'effectivement par rapport à des
différences entre eux nos différences et
la corruption
et oui c'est aujourd'hui se révolte
contre la corruption et cette corruption
même s'il faut faire découvrir des
restrictions à la liberté ça peut se
dessiner dans la corruption il faut
quand même rappeler que le régime de
bachar el-assad et le gouvernement de
bagdad ont répondu au printemps arabe
par l'artillerie lourde par des
bombardements ciblés sur des quartiers
d'habitation sur les hôpitaux sur des
écoles avec des barils beaubourg et de
tnt donc ce n'est pas seulement la
corruption c'est le fait que l'état
s'est rangé dans la population des
bandits aux yeux d'une
d'une part croissante de la population
ce qui fait que les gens ne le
reconnaissent plus là j'étais mis la
légitimité des instits donc sénateurs si
j'entends tout ça ne faisons surtout
rien est-ce que vous allez favorables
voient une intervention plus poussée que
sur le terrain certainement pas par
contre pour améliorer les frappes et
avoir une véritable réaction de
coalition que je ne vois pas aujourd'hui
oui on pourra en reparler c'est-à-dire
taper plus dur je crois qu'il faut
aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'on n'a
pas de stratégie quant au niveau
américain cela dit bara smaïl a
recueilli selon le réentendre le
documentaire nous n'avons pas de
séparation marginal il ya un point
particulier darche est aussi des
financements alors il ya bien sûr mais y
en a un qui se sont saisis mais il ya
aussi toute la contrebande sur le
pétrole dans les zones qui sont
maintenant dominé on voit qu'il ya des
centaines de camions qui livrent du
pétrole vers la turquie en contrebande
parfois vers l'armée syrienne d'ailleurs
de l'autre côté et on n'a pas frappé ses
véhicu alors c'est pas des combattants
tant que tel cd des assistants de neige
mais je trouve qu'un conducteur de
camion citerne est plus dangereux par
rapport à des gens que celui qu'a une
kalachnikov
donc ces deux fait un ennemi caton temps
pour décider qu'on frappe là où ça fait
mal c'est-à-dire l'argent est à dire les
besoins développés qui vont notamment
vers la turquie on le voit dans le
documentaire et dans le documentaire on
entend aussi ce trafiquant d'armes
syrien qui raconte comment les choses se
passent de commerce de pétrole
tout le monde connaît ça comment ça
marche
il brade le baril à 30 ou 32 dollars
c'est un gros business quelqu'un que je
connais qui travaillent avec eux je ne
vais pas dire sombre garder la dictée
peuvent gagner jusqu'à 10 millions de
dollars à certains endroits et on ne
fera pas parce que vous dites
les convois de véhicules en même temps
si vilain si je peux me permettre un oui
ou n'avais pas d'états d'âme là dessus
vous frappent leurs y est les les
congolais tout cas précédents qu'elle
essaie d'ét et râle c'est lorsqu'un
l'afghanistan général allemand a donné
or de frapper des convois de carburant
on a eu des centaines de dommages
collatéraux avec des enfants mais avec
une présence de drones satellitaire on
arrive malgré tout notamment quand les
camions citernes sont au puy à séparer
l'environnement je dirais des tribus
sunnites de ceux qui sont engagés dans
la contre bram à dire que c'est le
retour des fameuses frappes
chirurgicales
c'est chirurgicale c'est un oui mais on
a des armes dont on peut réduire l'effet
latéral on peut mieux encadrer il est
évident qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas une
réponse aérienne au niveau de ce qu'elle
devrait nous les comptes à pau
portefeuille mes contacts militairement
et en même temps militairement puisque
quand on va on voit une invasion vers
hamadi haute ya quand même des véhicules
qui arrivent
il n'y a pas que de la tribu sunnite
dans laquelle fructifie d'âge
il ya aussi la réalité de convois
militaires qui n'ont pas forcément été
détruits comme il aurait pu l'être
pourquoi je crois que d'abord parce
qu'il ya une géopolitique régionale qui
n'a pas fait l'objet d'une analyse les
stratégies de la turquie son principal
problème c'est pas assad c'est
évidemment le corps distance et le pkk
donc la façon dont ils vont gérer la
l'empêchement s'il laisse filer les
convois parce que leur objectif a eu ses
bas il ya les kurdes
quand il ya eu coban et rappelez vous
ces négociations qui ont duré des mois
pour que effectivement des kurdes
irakiens puisse traverser la frontière
turque passé par la turquie pour venir
aider à combler donc chacun des acteurs
à sa logique propre moi j'ai évidemment
mon souci c'est celui de l'arabie
saoudite mais il y en a d'autres qui ont
leur propre souffle légitimité à
intervenir et vous avez l'iran qui
effectivement va considérer non sans
raison que ma foi la défense des chip
lui incombent et donc ce qui m'a
beaucoup frappé c'est on était dans le
caïdat il ya encore deux ans tout à coup
on est passé dans les rangs en mettant
la pagaille en irak
et puis tout à coup quand nice et à
paris le nouvel ami est venu des ch
il n'y a aucune analyse géopolitique de
la région c'est à dire prenons le cas de
l'iran on a besoin de l'iran aujourd'hui
pour le liban pour la syrie pour l'irak
pour l'afghanistan pour le pakistan et
on fait comme si on avait plusieurs
ennemis et qu'on pouvait gérer une crise
avec tout le monde contre nous moi
j'avoue que je sais pas comme à tizi
ouzou décider comment se décide la
stratégie ce qui me frappe c'est
l'empilement des complicités
même si elles sont partielles même si
elles sont objectives autour de dice
quand même de très spectaculaire et tout
le monde l'espère finalement chacun a eu
chacun pour une bonne raison mahesh ou
un bout de dave à un moment ou un autre
à son profit contre un autre ennemi
c'est le cas de bachar al assad pendant
des années pendant des mois et des mois
entre 2012 et 2015
il a passé son temps à bombarder les
autres rebelles ceux qui défendent est
des principes laïques c'est pas vrai
mais disons libéraux démocratique là
qu'il a joué des ch contre les autres
oui parce que c'est plus facile d'avoir
des ch contre soit là d'un coup le monde
entier se ranger avec vous c'était son
but
la turquie pareil pour quoi bon ces
contremarques de pétrole elle existe
depuis les années 80 saddam hussein et
enfin où les années 90 le pilot margot
saddam hussein les a encouragés l'état
syrien aussi les encourager tous les
officiers des services de renseignement
frontalier de ces pays se sont enrichies
de ce trafic eh bien il continue il se
trouve que aujourd'hui c'est il est au
profit des choses pendant longtemps il a
été au profit de bachar el-assad ou de
saddam hussein donc c'est il ya des
sortes de solidarité ancien qui continue
peu importe à qui ça profite
et puis vous avez effectivement l'arabie
saudite qui a joué avec le feu
là où dix reconnaissent a dit bon on
peut pas se battre contre tout le monde
le problème c'est que c'est vrai on ne
mais je ne crois pas qu'ils aient de
bons dans l'histoire ne va pas du tout
fermé aujourd'hui en l'irrigation et
c'est peut-être la réussite de bachar
el-assad politique de choisir entre lui
et non parce qu'il a fait 228 morts
on le sait quoi c'est bon quand on
soutient aujourd'hui pour faire reculer
est-ce qu'une est organisée le matin
mais est-ce que bachar el-assad et
efficace pour lutter contre l' je vous
pose la question à vous l'avez vu à
palmyre sont à rebaisser débordé et il a
passé son il passe son temps armes et
des hélicoptères pour aller bombarder
des zones civiles
ça sert à rien plus d'accord avec vous
en ce qui concerne palmyre palmyre n'est
pas pro bachar un ou stratégique réel
il a intérêt à rassembler ses forces
plus à l'ouest du pays et se bat pour
palmyre qui est pour nous un symbole
n'est pas un pour lui
donc je crois qu'il faut bien faire la
différence entre ce que nous souhaitons
est ce que les syriens
d'un côté les iraniens doc le
gouvernement de bagdad par ailleurs qu
dont on pourrait beaucoup parlé et les
turcs ont des visions différentes mais
ne pensons pas que chacun des pays où
des acteurs va faire ce que nous
occidentaux nous voudrions qu'ils
fassent jamais dormir mais c'est pas une
stratégie ma question n'était pas celle
là ma question c'est de savoir si
aujourd'hui on peut se passer de bachar
al assad
est-ce qu'il faut renouer avec bachar al
assad je sais que c'est un gros mot
diplomatiquement mais je vous pose la
question sénateurs alors mon inquiétude
c'est que si le réduit qui se réduit
jour après jour de basher dans l'ouest
de la syrie
on retrouve encore des druzes et
chrétiens certain nombre de réfugiés
disparaissez d'un cheval à portes
ouvertes y compris vers la jordanie
compris vers le liban et est donc
d'inquiétude est là sachant
qu'aujourd'hui bachar tient aussi grâce
au hezbollah sans hezbollah bachar ne
tient plus on voit bien les limites donc
les capacités militaires iraniens que
l'iran soutient les tirages et depuis le
début ma les enfants et ils le
revendiquent puisque pour eux ils
combattent le monde sunnite et depuis le
début ils sont aux côtés de bachar m'a
pas répondu à ce qu'il faut renouer avec
bachar côté renouer peut-être pas
officiellement au contenu des deux cent
vingt mille morts mais en même temps il
faut bien prendre en compte que l' armée
syrienne libre dont on a rêvé n'est pas
capable de tenir face même donc vous
dites admis groupe ne le disons pas mais
faisons le voilà ce que vous êtes en
acceptant de travailler tout au moins de
taper dans les mêmes directions
en ce qui me concerne je vais choquer
moi je ne suis pas là pour juger en est
mais il me semble que ce serait la
solution que vous préconisez serait
peut-être la pire erreur parce que les
régimes en place ne sont pas des
interlocuteurs susceptibles d'ouvrir la
voie à une solution ils sont une partie
du problème et
c'est la grande question il faut
aujourd'hui proposer aux populations qui
ont fait allégeance à l'état islamique
mieux que l'état islamique donc ça mais
pas en renouant avec ceux qui sont les
bourreaux de ces communautés que nous
allons réussir
je crois qu'il ya eu un événement très
important s'est il y a quelques semaines
il y a eu le vote au congrès américain
d'une motion visant à permettre
l'armement direct des kurdes et des
arabes sunnites en irak sans passer par
le gouvernement central de bagdad
ce qui est la solution parce que l'art
médias car mais directement on sait et
il le reconnaître une légitimité
politique on ne le fait pas aujourd'hui
hélas les bombardements les raids
aériens n'ont qu'une conséquence c'est
de souder encore un peu plus sa
population autour de l'état islamique
je reconnais que l'argument de
pierre-jean luizard et efforts les
tribus sunnites notamment qui sont à la
limite de l'irak et la syrie ont été
rejetées complètement par le
gouvernement irakien qu'elle ne
reconnaissent plus et d'âge leur a
permis d'exister et le ramène donner un
pouvoir qu'ils ont retrouvé grâce à des
qu'est ce qu'on peut leur donner de plus
c'est bien joli de dire je vais les
armées mais actuellement ils sont dans
une zone contrôlée par des jld et donc
on peut paris allen général allen à
l'époque avait essayé de faire une garde
nationale sunnite
ça a capoté parce que malicki ne voulait
pas armer les sunnites
bien entendu parisien sans arrêt mais où
je rejoins unis où je rejoins je crois
les autres c'est que la réponse ne peut
pas être militaire
la réponse doit être politique et la
question qu'on se pose des uns des
autres et quand on l'avait auditionné il
m'avait beaucoup impressionné
c est ce que demain le moyen orient
ressemblera encore à l'image que nous en
avons aujourd'hui tout le monde je crois
dit non
il est évident qu'il va y avoir une
évolution des états des mouvements et on
est dans l'incertitude
elle comprend en vous écoutant pourquoi
d'âge prospère d'une certaine manière ce
sur des ruines d'une part sur des
régimes qui sont mal comportés c'est moi
qu'on puisse dire est sur des attitudes
qui sont les nôtres qui sont parfois
ambigu ou américaines qui ont pu être
ambigu
visiblement la france peut l'être aussi
parfois est-ce que ça a pour conséquence
d'avoir constitué une armée c'est à dire
un état islamique puisque c'est comme ça
que des cheveux s'appelait et qu'on ne
souhaite pas qu'il s'appelle une armée
constituée équipe est capable de faire
la guerre comme on la connaît ni le fait
qu'on la connaisse comme on la connaît
nous n'a pas d'importance dans le débat
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui ils ont une
armée et une force armée et
considérables est important et qu'il
m'en va probablement atteindre les
limites des zones sunnites avec
probablement une légitimité qui est
celle d'une révolution qui commence un
état pur composé de militants qui font
réplique qui applique une règle qui à
laquelle les gens adhèrent puisque c'est
là c'est le coran et c est donc cette
phase révolutionnaire on l'a connu à
toutes les révolutions au début
effectivement il ya une espèce de vision
à la cause les talibans aussi au début
on va se passer en iran
d'une certaine manière assurée le
renversement du shah il faut rappeler
une chose c'est qu'il y a un an quand
l'état islamique s'est emparé mossoul et
a dévalé la vallée du tigre jusqu'à
bagdad
ça s'est produit sans tirer un coup de
feu a donc la force de l'état islamique
de d'âge n'est pas militaire elle est à
seulement vaut une allée dans l orne à
la faiblesse de ceux qui sont face à
cette année aujourd'hui c'est quand même
une état islamique on va l'appeler comme
ça ou dess en tout cas à des armes des
temps que des hommes armés bien armés
beaucoup d'argent mais sa nomination
mais son oui mais son sa ressource la
plus forte
effectivement c'est pas les armes les
temps les sommes que c'est cette espèce
de dynamique qu'ils ont face à des états
faillis effectivement pour l'instant il
n'y a pas mieux à proposer je rejoins
mais oui en effet on apprend pollution
on ne demande pas de choisir entre deux
horreur moi je ne peux pas choisir
franchement entre bachar al assad qui a
fait mais dix fois pire que son père en
trois quatre ans et des ch
je ne peux pas choisir entre un
gouvernement irakien qui se conduit
comme une milice et des ch parce que je
suis désolé entre 2011 et 2013
j'allais en irak on vivait mal
on vivait super mal j'ai pour aller à
ramadi j'étais en 2013 à ramadi
il a fallu que je me cache et que je me
déguise quasiment au que je me cache
dans le coffre d'une voiture
parce que le gouvernement irakien ne
voulait pas laisser un seul étranger à
les rencontrer les gens qui
manifestaient à l'époque pacifiquement
depuis six mois pour obtenir la
libération des prisonniers politiques et
c'est un certain nombre de le droit
d'être embauchée dans l'armée dans la
police à l'ipp ça ça a duré deux ans on
en a rien rien n'arrive vous ne pouvez
pas choisir même si au bout du compte la
france se trouve au haut des basques
asie ou au bout d'un kamikaze
dans les deux cas c'est ma question dans
les deux cas vous aurez le même résultat
que vous choisissez l'un ou l'autre on
va pas être pour des ch
mais on va pas être pour bachar al assad
j'entends jean temps j'entends des
positions de principe des positions
morales des positions aussi de deux
journalistes puis j'entends des
positions militaires chez vous qui
disent on peut être un tout petit peu
plus pragmatique d'une certaine manière
vis-à-vis de bachar qui peut nous aider
il ya une autre arme dont dispose des ch
c'est internet on le voit dans le
documentaire c'est un groupe qui
maîtrise à la perfection la
communication et le marketing
les hommes en noir du fus sur internet
des clips de propagande digne de
production hollywoodienne dans
lesquelles ils célèbrent la naissance de
leur nouvel état
il invente même un slogan barria l'état
islamique restera
un slogan de campagne comme le yes we
can de barack obama
c'est du marketing d'ailleurs ce
discours restera c'est dire que même
s'ils peuvent retourner dans la
clandestinité
même s'il peut être affaibli par des
tabacs rien sous-entendu l'amérique ne
peut pas gagner
ça a été très fort libé que ce barria
est un yes we can
c'est à dire que des chars tournée
larmes de la communication entre
l'amérique d'une série la manière contre
le christ très hollywoodienne
n'oubliez pas ça parce que la violence
dans les séries hollywoodiennes est de
même nature que celle qu'on voit sur les
vidéos de neige simplement il faut
expliquer aux incas c'est faux et dans
un cas c'est vrai mais pour des jeunes
qui vit dans un monde virtuel pourquoi
voulez-vous qui est une espèce de
violence des séries télévisées des films
américains et c est que dans l'autre
côté jaoui ça c'est de la violence
illégitime moi j'ai toujours en tête un
exemple qui va frapper american sniper
est un film de propagande qui a son
équivalent sur internet avec juba qui
est un sniper irakien et les deux sont
construits sur le même logique
c'est à dire un enfant au frais dans
l'hérault un titre études étaient des
adversaires des ennemis à un kilomètre
et demi de distance le film de ou tony
sinimale le héros en question - l'année
oui mais les duels par un groupe qui a
été traumatisé par la guerre alors que
lui ne l'a pas été il s'embête lentilles
rentrer aux états unis regardent les
informations sur ce qui se passe en irak
non je veux dire c'est un film de
propagande il faut le qualifier comme
tels et quand vous êtes un musulman et
vous voyez ce film où les irakiens ce ne
sont que des hypocrite cruel et
cetera
vous avez une folle envie c'est de
partir au gua travail d'âge le hezbollah
au liban faisait sa fille mais les
drapeaux ou les prises de guerre ou même
les attentats contre les convois
israélien l'époque non oui l'histoire
des actions kamikazes à l'époque moderne
effectivement nous ramène à mohamed
merah ses films et à l'école ans
shit en l'occurrence celle celle du
hezbollah mais ce qui est ce qui est
important je crois c'est la
compréhension cas aujourd'hui l'état
islamique daraîche de la puissance de
l'image je crois que c'est ahmed al
anani qui est un des dirigeants de
l'état islamique qui a dit au 21e siècle
on ne gagne pas une guerre par les armes
mais par l'image et il a très bien
compris comment aujourd'hui nos sociétés
démocratiques sont incroyablement
sensible à cette image
et comment à travers un discours qui
cible des individus et auquel peuvent
être sensibles autant le manque d'une
tribu dans la province d'al-anbar en
irak que des jeunes de la banlieue de
montréal de melbourne ou de paris
comment un tel discours peut faire
mouche parce que ils touchent des cordes
sensibles et c'est probablement l'une
des prouesses de l'état islamique
on est d'accord sur le chiffre des
jeunes français jeunes ou moins jeunes
d'ailleurs qu'ils se trouvent
aujourd'hui enrôlé dans l'armée des
kamikazes ou des djihadistes de dice
plus de nîmes paris de 900 $ à 900 euros
le mans ou langues
mais ce qui est beaucoup plus
significatif c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
pense qu'à une centaine de pays qui sont
représentées dans les combattants
étrangers de dèche
c'est ça qui est excitant c'est ça c'est
ça la véritable dimension internationale
vous avez bien évidemment des
tchétchènes
ça c'est une évidence et des maghrébins
une flopée tunisiens qui sont arrivés
vous avez évidemment des familles la
ligue les belges et les chiffres les
français si on compare par rapport à la
communauté musulmane française sont
proportionnellement moins mobilisé que
le font par exemple des pays comme la
grande bretagne la belgique ou le modèle
communautariste à emporter et donc
paradoxalement notre modèle de laïcité a
plutôt et efficaces s'ils voulaient dans
la mobilisation moi c'est mon sentiment
si je regardais télévision et si
j'écoute les radios françaises j'ai
l'impression exactement inverses cela
pose les matins vous regardez les
chiffres nous avons utilisé à l'arrivée
la concluant contraire le départ
proportionnelle de belges est beaucoup
plus important que le décor de grands
voiliers une chose qui nous frappe c'est
que derrière on maîtrise les codes des
deux sociétés celle où elle est et celle
qu'elle vise là où nous maîtrisons pas
les codes l'autre société
c'est le connaître on est nul pour le
combat j'ai jamais vu un clip de
propagande convaincant fait par les
américains en dix ans d'occupation
d'irak
jamais ils ont une salle de télé il ya
les vidéos et les clips de
déradicalisation oui prête à sourire
le gouvernement le service d'information
du gouvernement étaient les clips comme
ella qui vous font sourire pour lui ça
prête à sourire parce que c'est d'une
d'une naïveté on se doute bien que ça ne
peut pas avoir d'effet peut-être par
rapport ce que vient de dire pire
connaisseurs mais il me semble qu'au
contraire notre idéal républicain
français est particulièrement visée est
particulièrement questionner parce que
comme tous les universalisme il y a des
manques et dans notre universalisme
français l'un des manques les plus
criants c'est la question de l'identité
de savoir qui on est et qu'est ce que
signifie être français et c'est ce qui a
très bien compris daraîche en essayant
de créer dans notre société
des réactions communautaire enchaîne par
un terrorisme visant les juifs ou
d'autres communautés mis à table et moi
cedej qui est responsable des attentats
sur le sol français et kwasi par exemple
ont été formés plus tôt il y est mais
non qu'en syrie où on y allie l'idée
c'est de provoquer des réactions
communautaire et force est de constater
que depuis les attentats de janvier le
regard que les communautés en france
portent les unes sur les autres a changé
et n'a pas changé dans le bon sens il ya
un ministère des maliens comme si on
allait lui réalisé la réaction a été au
contraire très positive la mobilisation
de classes moyennes musulmane pour dire
nous sommes français nous sommes
républicains a été énorme et donc
effectivement vous avez une frange à
laquelle on n'accède pas qui sont celles
de ces salafistes niçois qui étaient
saouls qui soit 10 à 10
mais fondamentalement sur les cinq à
sept millions de musulmans français vous
avez défendez des attitudes d'adhésion à
la république et donc ça si le phénomène
va avoir énormément on aurait un
antivirus en tout cas les a intégrés à
la salle étaient présents pour vous moi
j'attendais moi j'ai toujours constaté
que la poêle à la mobilisation de la
communauté musulmane par ses élites
intellectuelles artistes et c'est raté
je parle pas du cfcm
mais il ya eu une mobilisation
républicaine moi j'ai été invité l'année
dernière une douzaine de séminaires
provoquées par des associations locales
sur le thème la radicalisation qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire contre des associations
musulmanes
donc on va pas faire comme si notre
modèle était en crise la france est le
pays qui a la plus grosse communauté
juive le plus grosse commune au terminal
la plus grosse communauté chinoise est
la plus grosse communauté musulmane de
l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne dire que le modèle
républicain est en crise mais gêne un
peu ok on l'entend c'est la première je
crois que c'est la première paroles
positives que j'entends dans ce débat
sur la situation face à des jeux le
souligner voilà qu'après évidemment on
peut continuer en débattre on a entendu
que vous étiez alors directement parce
qu'on leur fournit l'argumentaire des
champs dans une politique extérieure de
double standard mais qui est scandaleuse
qui est scandaleuse quand vous trouvez
sur un site à l'affice 2000 morts à gaza
ne fait rien quatre occidentaux égorgé
sur internet on envoie l'armée
que voulez-vous répondre un argument
pareil rien il ya un ministère des
martyrs comme j'ai lu intégré a déj
probablement le recrutement des s'occupe
des familles de leurs combattants morts
et et de former et de former ceux qui
les rejoignent pour en faire des
kamikazes y compris c'est pas comment
dirigeons pas inventé moi je trouve
qu'il ya un investissement entre
d'acheter le hezbollah qui me frappe sur
certaines choses et notamment j'ai
l'impression que dice et la revanche
déçu ni ils voulaient le harris bola et
pilot rue c'est à dire une organisation
efficace qui fait peur transnationales
et qui nettement plus efficace que les
l'état dans lequel l es ben laden si
longtemps par l'iran les encore we die
chez financé par lui-même oui par son
père olle ça fait une grosse différence
non mais c'est pas c'est pas une
duplication concession du fonctionnement
c'est une sorte de deux façons de
reconquérir
une image de puissance de fierté et de
l'efficacité militaire
après des années et des années de racler
d'échec dire se désole et pendant ça
fait 20 ans que les armées des pays
arabes sunnites
subissent défaite sur défaite que ce
soit face à l'iran face à israël
les récitants beaucoup plus renouvelé
l'art de la guerre dans le monde
arabo-musulman de 419 que effectivement
les sunnites donc ce sentiment des chats
qu'il est aussi dans le mimétisme
aujourd'hui le martyr ce n'est pas une
invention unis il ya une zone de tir
venu de syrie récemment la qui est
revenu parce que justement il trouvait
calice d'attendre pour les suisses ils
étaient trop longs qu'est ce qu'il va
faire en france et bayer on sait pas si
la pologne est en prison donc la
question là il fait comme blanc pour
l'instant ils ont prises en fait c'est
ça donc mais il est la liste d'attenté
trop longues donc il n'a pas tout parce
que ma question d'après la suivante des
fabriques une forme d'idéal qui attire
recrute forme notamment à l'attentât
suicide
vous dites il ya des listes d'attentes
tout le monde peut pas passer à la
caisse assez rapidement et ceux qui
reviennent en france est ce que l'un des
buts de dèche
par exemple c'est de faire des attentats
suicides sur le territoire occidental
français en particulier
est ce que c'est un but inscrit ou pas
encore ou pas du tout dans la propagande
de l'état islamique il y a d'abord une
première étape qui est mettre à bas les
états arabes tels qu'ils existent
aujourd'hui avec en filigrane ensuite
viser israël est évidemment les
démocraties occidentales sont considérés
comme l'étape suivante dans toutes les
vidéos dans tous les discours de l'état
islamique on voit que ils sont d'un sur
une lancée
qui va les mener à jérusalem à médine à
la mecque et ensuite avec la conquête de
rome et de l'europe dans con on est dans
un messianisme tels que le monde
musulman en a connu à plusieurs on est
inscrit si j'ose dire sur la route mais
vous êtes en train de me dire on n'est
pas une priorité aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je l'état islamique par
exemple ne et
ne parle pas beaucoup d'israël mais on
voit que pour lui la priorité ce sont
notamment les états de création
mandataire l'irak la syrie le liban la
jordanie ça a été dit de façon explicite
dans votre documentaire mais évidemment
il y a dans la propagande une un côté
planétaire un choc des civilisations
tels que l'état indien mais
militairement parlant nous ne sommes pas
une priorité aujourd'hui
alors est-ce qu'on peut repartir au
moins tranquille avec cette idée
pardonne moi dans le champ de ruines
oui par rapport al qaïda étaient eux ils
ont théorisé le fait de se battre contre
l'ennemi proches ben laden avait après
moult réflexions hésitations et
aller-retour théorisé le fait de frapper
l'ennemi lointain
ça n'empêche pas qu'on forme aujourd'hui
des jeunes gens j'ai encore une fois
jeunes ou moins jeunes qui peuvent
revenir demain oui sachant qu'il y a pas
besoin qu'ils reviennent pas les avoir
sur place et n'ont pas besoin d'avoir
fait un aller-retour pour être des
terroristes potentiels pour ce qu'ils
sont des structures et qui sont
pervertis par le salafisme des secondes
tel qu'on le voit donc je crois que le
fait que des chenaux pas placer
l'occident et la france en particulier
comme une priorité ne nous met pas à
l'abri d'attentats si on intervient
encore plus de et ce sera ma dernière
question encourent plus de risques
d'être une cible ou est ce que ce sera
de toute manière le même ordre de
priorité autrement dit est-ce qu'on a un
court un risque d'attentât en france si
on n'intervient plus virilement en syrie
j'ai interviewé déjà présent à travers
les forces aériennes et personne je
crois mais envisage sérieusement
militairement d'aller au sol il faudrait
que l'armée irakienne de bagdad
tantôt qui n'est pas au niveau c'est
clair les pêches merga et les
volontaires chiites arrive à tenir tout
au moins en irak
mais il est évident qu aucun pays
occidental envie de mettre des troupes
au sol parce que c'est pas simplement
lutter contre quelques terroristes d'al
qaïda au sahel c'est vraiment trente
mille hommes armés et c'est pas du tout
la même réponse militaire que nous
aurions affaire
donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui aucun
politique aucun militaire occidentale
n'envisage sérieusement d'aller au sol
merci à tous les cas pour pour ce débat
on s'arrête là on aurait pu continuer
deux heures
vous pouvez continuer évidemment à
laisser vos messages sur le mail de
l'émission qui s'inscrit en bas de votre
écran j'ai été très heureux de passer
cette année avec vous sur public sénat
les deux prochaines semaines vous
retrouverez claire barsacq qui va mettre
le cap dans huit jours ça changera
radicalement de sujets et d'ambiance sur
avignon et son festival
à bientôt